Harry Kersh: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Chipotle in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
This is a UK chicken burrito.
We've also got some black
beans, some white rice,
some lettuce, cheese, sour
cream, guac as well inside.
We're gonna measure the length, the–
[auto-tuned record scratch]
I don't want to say girth.
Producer: You're gonna have to say girth.
I'm gonna make you.
Harry: Aw, man.
Producer: There's going
to be a lot of girth
in this episode.
Harry: Game face.
We're gonna measure the length,
the girth, and the weight of this burrito.
So, our burrito is 7 inches long.
Joe Avella: I have the same
burrito Harry has right here.
Well, not the same one. The same order.
I don't know where the burrito
ends and the tinfoil begins,
so I'm kind of eyeballing it.
It looks to be about
between 7 1/4 and 7 1/2 inches.
Harry: A girth of 10 inches.
[saucy guitar music]
It has a girth of –
[laughs]
I promise I'm a professional.
Joe: Its circumference –
girth, really?
Going all the way around.
Almost exactly 10 inches.
Burrito is a 10, if you're
thinking about making it a tux.
[upbeat suave music]
Harry: And, finally, it weighs...
more than the scale can handle.
This isn't even the big boy.
Joe: Hey, told you guys
to get a new scale.
We got a new scale.
Harry: Bear with us.
[distant screaming]
Harry: So, we're gonna weigh
this burrito half at a time
to see what the total is.
Half one, 310.
And then this one,
plus I'll get the scraps from the plate.
So, combined, the two halves
of our burrito weighed 597 grams.
Joe: Chipotle's burrito order weighed –
man, that's hefty.
That is a hefty boy.
Harry: In the UK, we can
also get our burritos
in bowl form.
This bowl contains the same
ingredients as our burrito,
but obviously without the tortilla wrap.
Let's weigh it and see
what it measures up to.
So, this one came out to
pretty much exactly 500 grams,
which, even with the bowl factored in,
is, like, 100 grams less than the burrito.
Joe: So, this here is that
same burrito ingredients
in bowl form.
Whoa, gonna have to go this way.
Oh, wow, I'm really smart.
Wait, is it heavier?
Wow. So, correct me if I'm wrong,
but there's more here than
there was in the burrito.
Harry: Finally, we can get our meals
in the form of a salad.
Now, this has all the same
ingredients as our bowl,
but without the rice.
Let's weigh it and see how
much difference that makes.
Strangely enough, this came to pretty much
exactly 500 grams, the
same as the burrito bowl.
Joe: And here is the salad
version of that bowl,
which was the bowl
version of that burrito.
Sticking with me so far?
Being weighed.
I do want to point out, this
does have white rice on it.
I mean, salad is boring and disgusting.
I would never get one.
Harry: In the UK, you
can only get one size
of chips on the side,
and that's roughly this many.
Some of these are a little bit fractured,
so I will just try and form
whole chips where I can.
I'm like the Banksy of tortilla chips.
Banksy, you've done it again.
29, 30, and a half.
Joe: At a US Chipotle, you
have two sizes of chips,
the regular
and the large.
Regular chips first.
That's gonna take forever.
All right, one.
[fast-forwarding]
25, 30, 35, some broken ones.
[normal speed] A regular
bag is roughly 41 chips.
Now let's count the large.
75, 76.
Nearly double for the large
bag of chips at Chipotle.
Very nice.
Harry: In the UK, we can only get
one size of guac on the side.
It's supposed to be 4 ounces.
We're gonna measure it to
check if that's the case.
Ours was just shy of 4 ounces,
so pretty much right.
Joe: The guac in the US,
of course, comes in two sizes as well,
and I'm gonna weigh
them just to make sure.
Just to keep them honest.
I don't know how much
the measuring cup is.
So it should be over
4 ounces, if anything.
3.75.
[clears throat]
That's including the cup,
which, correct me if I'm
wrong, you do not eat.
Skimping on the guac.
Don't act like 0.25
ounces isn't that much.
If it's not that much,
then put it in there.
8 o-zeezers.
It's a little over 7.
Zoom in on that. I want
to shame these people.
Shame on you, Chipotle.
You already charged us extra for it,
and you're also just not giving us
as much as we pay for.
Tsk,
tsk!
Harry: And, finally, we have tacos.
Oh, hell, yeah.
When we looked at the menu,
they were only available
in a portion size of three.
In the UK, this taco
is 6 inches in length.
We got a veggie taco,
which includes guac, salsa, sour cream,
cheese, fajita vegetables,
and black beans.
And ours weighs....
Joe: At a US Chipotle,
you can get tacos in orders
of one, two, or three.
This guy's falling apart.
It's a 6-incher.
And, of course,
I did not get a vegetarian taco.
This one has meats aplenty.
So it has different ingredients
than the one that they weighed,
making this weighing completely arbitrary!
Harry: Now, this [burrito thuds]
is the biggest burrito you
can get at a UK Chipotle.
We chose chicken as the base,
but then we added every
other meat as an add-on,
and we've also got all the
vegetables and all the salsas.
They were a bit reluctant to make this,
but eventually they got it done,
and it seems to not be leaking,
so good job, guys.
Joe: This right here is the
biggest burrito you can get
at a Chipotle in the US.
So big, in fact, I named it the Big Boy.
Got that?
Fantastic.
OK, "What's in it?" you ask.
Well, it's a carnitas
burrito with double carnitas,
and I also got double barbacoa.
Of course it's double wrapped,
because it has guacamole,
white rice, fajita veggies,
black beans, queso blanco, mild tomato,
I actually got all the salsas,
sour cream, cheese, and lettuce.
This runs about $18.20 in the US,
which is about 13 pounds and 16 shillings.
Harry: This burrito set
me back 16 pounds 75,
which is around $22,
which is quite expensive.
You're looking at kind of 2
pounds 70 per meat you add in,
so, honestly, if you're looking
for just quantity for lunch,
it's probably cheaper to
just get two single burritos.
Now, it's the same length
as the other burrito,
coming in at 7 inches,
but you do get one extra inch of girth.
And, as we all know, a little goes –
[laughs]
As we all know, a little goes a long way.
Joe: Now I will measure the length
and thickness of this one.
Almost 9 inches.
OK, it's about 8 3/4.
Yo, this guy's a lot thicker.
So, that's about 11 1/2
inches of thickness.
It's much bigger.
Harry: What about the calories?
Well, this is the most
popular burrito from Chipotle.
It contains eight ingredients:
chicken, white rice,
black beans, sour cream,
guacamole, cheese, fresh
tomato salsa, and lettuce.
This contains 1,320 calories,
540 of which are from fat.
It does contain 2,610 milligrams of sodium,
which is 113% of your daily allowance.
Joe: And in the US, that same burrito,
according to Chipotle, is the exact same nutrition
and calorie count.
They use the same smallwares and utensils
to make the burritos in the
UK as they do in the US,
so everything should
technically be the same.
That's what their PR people told us.
And, hey, if you can't trust
a major conglomerate's PR people,
who can you trust, right?
And if you get that
same order in salad form
and didn't put rice on
your salad like a maniac,
that would bring this calorie
count down to about 800,
and it lowers the sodium
to "only" 1,520 milligrams,
or 66% of what you should have in the day.
Chipotle also gives you the option
of having their vinaigrette
salad dressing on the side,
which adds 220 calories,
bumping it back up over
1,000 to 1,020 calories
and bumping up the sodium
to 2,327 milligrams,
or 101% of your daily –
basically, it's liquid salt.
What's with the...? Jeez.
Harry: If you choose to get
your burrito in a bowl form,
that loses you 320 calories,
bringing it down to an even 1,000.
Now it's only around 40% of
your daily caloric allowance.
It still contains 1,855
milligrams of sodium, however.
In the UK, a side of
chips is 540 calories.
Joe: Same with our regular chips here.
Now, if you upgrade to the large,
that's going to be 810 calories.
Harry: If you were to enjoy
these with a side of guac,
that's an extra 230 calories.
Joe: Now, if you wanted to
upgrade to the large guac,
that's gonna be an
additional 460 calories.
Harry: Now, Chipotle as
a brand prides themself
on being quite a healthy option.
They're not using too many
artificial ingredients.
In the US, they actually make a big deal
of only needing 53 ingredients
across the entire menu.
However, in the UK, when we totaled up
all of the ingredients, we found 67.
So, as you all know if
you watch "Food Wars,"
that's kind of unusual
that there's more things
in the US than in the UK.
Joe: The only ingredient
in the US Chipotle
that gave me a bit of pause
was something called gypsum.
Gypsum's also known as calcium
sulfate [di]hydrate, right?
OK, and Chipotle uses
that in their tofu process
when they separate the
chunks from the liquid.
Gypsum is also found in
drywall, chalk, and shampoo.
Of course it is.
Now, does the gypsum stay in the tofu,
or is it just used for
the separating purposes?
I don't care.
I'm never getting tofu from Chipotle.
Harry: Put the beast back in front of me.
Let's look at some ingredients
for the flour tortillas.
In the UK, the tortillas
contain fortified wheat flour
(wheat flour, calcium carbonate, iron,
niacin, thiamine, water,
vegetable oils (palm oil, rapeseed oil),
wholemeal flour, salt, and raising agents
(sodium carbonate,
diphosphates, and malic acid).
Joe: In the US,
our flour tortilla only
has four ingredients.
Wheat flour, water, canola oil, and salt.
That's it.
Huh.
Harry: Now I know how
Joe feels when we film
pretty much all of these episodes,
because it's not very nice
to have that many things in your food
knowing that the other side doesn't.
Like, why do we need it but they don't?
It's weird.
Now, given the fact that we
have way more ingredients
in the UK than in the US,
it does beg the question
as to why the calorie count
for their tortillas is the same.
We did reach out to
Chipotle for explanation,
but unfortunately at
the time of recording,
they hadn't got back to us.
Besides the tortillas,
a lot of the other fillings at Chipotle
have pretty similar ingredients lists
in the UK and the US,
maybe with some minor
differences in the spices used.
For example, the chicken
in the UK is flavored
with chicken, water, chile
de árbol and jalapeño,
cumin, garlic, oregano, black pepper,
sea salt, and sunflower oil.
Joe: Whereas our chicken
is chicken, obviously,
water, chipotle chili, cumin,
garlic, oregano, black pepper, salt,
distilled vinegar, and sunflower oil.
All words I can pronounce! Huzzah!
Harry: Our guacamole is pretty simple.
It only has six ingredients.
Avocado, red onion, jalapeño,
citrus juice, sea-salt
flakes, and coriander,
which is what we call cilantro,
and we're definitely right.
Joe: US guac is very similar.
Avocado, cilantro or coriander,
whatever it's called,
jalapeños, lemon juice, lime
juice, onions, and salt.
Harry: A serving of white rice
in the UK is made of
long-grain white rice,
bay leaf, sunflower oil, coriander,
citrus juice, and sea-salt flakes.
Joe: And our white rice in
the US contains white rice,
bay leaf, cilantro,
lemon juice, lime juice,
rice-bran oil, salt, and water.
Harry: Finally, our Monterey
Jack cheese contains milk,
starter cheese culture,
sea-salt flakes, and enzymes.
Don't know which enzymes. Just enzymes.
The concept of enzymes.
Joe: Whereas our cheese
contains cheese curds,
nope. Cheese cultures,
milk, salt, and vegetable rennet.
Rennet?
Ren-net.
I don't know what that is.
Harry: Here is everything
you will only find
on the menu at a UK Chipotle.
Joe: These are all the
US-exclusive items at Chipotle.
Harry: Now, we only have
one exclusive food item
on the menu in the UK,
and that is the protein pump bowl.
It contains rice, a
double order of chicken,
some lettuce, some salsa, and some cheese.
Joe: This first one right
here is the whole 30 bowl,
for those of you on the whole 30 diet.
In the middle...
cheat sheet No. 2,
this is the paleo bowl,
and that is a chicken
salad with guacamole,
lettuce, fajita veggies, chicken,
and the medium green salsa.
And the last bowl over here
is the protein pump bowl.
It's got all that stuff in it.
This right here is
Chipotle's queso cheese.
Not available in the UK.
What is the story with this?
They figured out a way to
make natural melted cheese,
and I gotta tell you,
this stuff is really good.
[crunching]
Yeah. Oh, man.
Like, their queso is trouble.
I love that stuff.
It's really good.
A protein that you can get
in the US is carne asada.
You can get that instead of the steak.
And cauliflower rice.
Now, there was no
cauliflower rice available
at the Chipotles we
went to for this video,
but besides that, I went ahead
and made a US Only Chipotle taco.
It's just a queso and carne asada taco.
I figured a burrito
of just carne asada and
queso is a little ridiculous.
This is like what I would have gotten
when I was in the seventh grade as a kid,
just melted cheese and
meat and nothing else.
So, here we go.
Yeah.
[mumbles]
[upbeat jazzy music]
I love the queso. It's incredible.
Carne asada's really good.
Chipotle also has a children's menu.
You can get two tacos or quesadillas.
I was surprised to learn
with the tacos for the kids' meal,
you get one meat and two toppings.
Yes, kids are picky eaters.
But only two toppings, mom and dad?
Only two?
Also, it comes with your choice
of chocolate milk or apple juice.
Harry: What we lack in
exclusive food options
and in fountain drinks
we really make up for in
cans and bottles of drink.
So, let's start with
these things over here,
which are Tenzing brand
natural energy drinks.
It's kind of like when you
want a Red Bull slash coffee,
but you don't want the
guilt associated with it.
Then we have this very
fancily named Fentimans,
which is kind of like a sparkling water
flavored with elderflower.
Personally, not a huge fan of elderflower,
but some people are, and that's OK.
Next, we have this
Turmeric and Mango Nourish
from Humble Warrior.
Next up, we've got these
cans of Dash Water,
which, I think they're just water
that's kind of lightly flavored again.
We have orange juice,
we have Berry Set Go,
and we have Wonder Green,
if you want something nice and healthy.
Chipotle's kind of gone for a fancier vibe
with these, by the looks of things.
These are all kind of the fancier brands.
At the end of the day, they
are kind of just sodas,
but they're ones that are
just a bit more upmarket
than you might normally find.
A personal highlight is that Chipotle
in the UK sells San Pellegrino.
I don't know if you guys
have this in the US,
but it's basically a brand
of sparkling fruit juices.
I really love their lemonade.
It's, like, really tangy and acidic.
And then, finally, if you want to,
you can finish off your meal with a beer.
Joe: Looks like the ones over there
in the UK are pretty much different
than the ones we have in the US,
and this is not even all of them.
I have the Nantucket Nectars,
which is juice.
I see these are Iz? Izze?
You guys had the cans of
the San Pellegrino water.
We just have the bottle of the plain,
which I actually prefer.
Yo. Organic black tea.
And right here,
the best one,
Mexican Coke.
Harry: It really sucks
that America is so obsessed
with high-fructose corn syrup,
because our Coke I think is similar
to Mexican Coke and just
made with regular sugar.
Would you like a tortilla chip
having been loosely fondled by me?